Anthony thank you for coming on the
podcast I really appreciate you taking
the time happy to be here so I figured a
good place to start would be with your
favorite movie of all time in time why
is that your favorite movie uh it's got
a great life message that I think most
people uh you spend your entire life
um looking at the thing you have to do
that day or that week uh what's going
wrong with your life but you miss kind
of the entire point which is you only
have so many days hours you know minutes
uh and that movie takes great life
lessons and it puts it into a super
cheesy stupid movie uh which for those
who haven't seen it Justin Timberlake uh
it's the Stars already like not the
movie that you would expect most people
to think that's a great movie and uh
they have a clocks in their forearm and
literally they go to work uh as they're
leaving work they like put their forearm
underneath like a punch clock
essentially and more time is deposited
into their clock and you get to live
until you run out of time uh and if you
go to work you keep getting more time
but the thing is that the people at the
lowest end of the socioeconomic status
or latter they only get 24 hours for
every day that they work so you
literally if you don't come back to work
the next day you're going to run out of
time you're going to die whereas the
wealthy people uh have essentially
unlimited time right they they have uh
thousands and thousands of days in their
uh kind of forums and there's a couple
of things that are really interesting
about that movie uh outside of just the
message of take times important or times
your most valuable asset but there's a
scene where
um Justin Timberlake is able to move
into kind of a higher status area and uh
when he gets out of the car he runs into
the building and somebody basically like
stops and goes hey man what are you
doing and he's like ah what are you
talking about and they're like why are
you running and he's like because
doesn't everyone run because in the
lower socioeconomic sense everyone's
running constantly and it's got this
like metaphor for like they're on the
rat race they're they're on the hamster
wheel they can't get off
but when he moves to the higher socio uh
economic status uh in that Community
running is looked down upon we have
unlimited time why are you going to rush
enjoy it walk slow down right and so
like there's all these little pieces of
the movie if you just watch it for like
a cinematic uh experience like whatever
this shitty movie
um but if you look at it from like the
message it has uh it's just really
powerful uh through that lens when did
you realize time was an important aspect
of your own life
um 2008 uh it was a weird thing where
time actually isn't the thing uh that is
valuable I don't think most people
realize time is valuable I think there's
something else that they realize and
then the the kind of uh lesson of uh
that conclusion is the time thing so for
me
um in 2008 I was in Iraq uh a gentleman
uh was shot and killed and it just hit
me I was 20 years old and it was like oh
[ __ ] we all die like unfortunately that
guy it was today uh but that's gonna
happen to all of us and I think that you
almost have this like uh reverse
response where some people go to a very
dark place and unfortunately uh that
wasn't me but on the other hand you can
go down this path of like holy [ __ ] I'm
lucky to uh uh um and fortunate to
constantly be able to wake up every day
and so what you do is you start to like
get more out of each day
um and I joke all the time that like
some of the happiest people I know and
some of the saddest and like most
depressed people I know all went to war
so it's very much like if you both went
through the same experience how does
somebody come out depressed somebody
comes out super happy with like the rest
of their life it's all about like the
mindset and perspective
what other lessons did you learn that
might not appear obvious or are unusual
from your time in War uh violence rules
the world like which sounds you know
kind of basic but like uh we live cushy
lives where we offload and Outsource uh
the defense of our country of our cities
uh of our families and even of ourselves
to people who go do things that maybe we
don't want to know so much about
um and so uh that is like a very
fortunate position for us to be in
because most people
Who special people who are listening to
this who have an hour of their day to
listen to a podcast like you got a cushy
ass life
um and so uh uh they don't have to worry
about like tonight I'm gonna go home and
I hope no my neighbor doesn't try to
come over and like rob me of the food in
my home right and so uh there are places
in the world where like that is exactly
what happens and so violence definitely
rules the world
um in certain areas and and I think
we're fortunate not to have to deal with
on a day-to-day basis uh the second
thing is around like leadership uh in
the military it's very hierarchy article
so uh I'm a sergeant you're a private
you do what I say because literally I
have a rank on my chest in the
quote-unquote real world uh that's not
really how it works like yes there's
hierarchical structures but it's a lot
more like influential leadership and so
what you begin to realize is like
there's different ways to lead and
different ways to uh kind of execute as
a team
um and so you have to understand not
just how to be a leader how to be what
type of leader in what type of situation
and so you get you get into like the
sign science of it and really unpack
that and the last thing I would say uh
is
um like you would be shocked at what
your body and mind can go through and do
when pushed to the Limit and uh a great
example of this was actually in uh basic
training
um I sent Runner but not like uh you
know there's guys who show up and
they're running six minute miles and
you're just like I don't know how you do
that and uh one morning uh we got out
into formation they were like okay like
group a group b Group C and uh I'm idiot
I think a time I was 17 years old and
they were like group a I was like I'm
[ __ ] in group a like group a sound
like they're in the front when I didn't
know is group a was the fast group and
so they don't tell you how far you're
gonna run you just go and everyone's
running in basically a formation so like
there's no like falling out like
basically if you're going to not keep up
you like kind of move off to the side
and there's a truck going behind you
just get in the truck and like in basic
training it's not like a Seal training
or Special Forces I think we're like
kicked out it's more so just like hey
you probably shouldn't run with group a
you get like demoted to group b or c
I remember this one day we were running
and as fast I ever [ __ ] around my
life like I was dying and we end up
running and running and running and
running and like in the back of my head
I was just like I can't be the dude who
quits first right like uh I recently had
a conversation with Kyle Larson Navy
SEAL and he was like uh in in uh buds uh
SEAL training uh people quit in twos so
people turned their buddy like y'all
quit if you quit wow but like for
whatever reason I was like I can't be
the first one to fall back and so we ran
we ran five miles and six minute miles
and never done that my life before and
we got to the other end and I was
weren't like I was done but I understand
myself like I don't think if you had
told me like my it was life or death
this morning I had to run you know five
miles in uh in 30 minutes I don't think
I could have done it wow and so you
realize very quickly like damn we don't
merely push the limits of our bodies and
Minds uh and it really helps like the
military does a great job of doing that
because it's all in a group and you
don't think about it wow that's that's
really impactful now when you are asked
about this time
how much of you is a different person
right I think this happens a lot in
podcasts where people will ask people
about things in their past and they're
actually not that person anymore yeah so
how much do you feel like the person who
went to the Army and went overseas it's
kind of like um if uh uh if you have
like a software product right and it has
different like interfaces like that's
kind of how I think most humans are uh
you see it on social media like the way
you act on LinkedIn is different than
the way you act on Twitter or Instagram
or on email or whatever uh I think your
life generally is like that as well uh
and it's always weird when like somebody
who's used to interacting with you at
work then like sees you with your like
high school friends and I'm like dude
you guys are weird right or they're like
I'm the same way right so like I I think
through the Journey of life like we have
that similar type of thing uh the
military experience was definitely like
a certain box in time uh but there was a
lot of commonalities Right Where um I'm
like super OCD about being on time like
my wife will tell you like if I'm late
to something I'm like not okay and it's
probably because it was ingrained in me
in the military then playing football
right like all these things and so now
it's just like that's just who I am no
point in trying to change it no point in
like being upset about it it's just like
I have to be on time if I'm not on time
I [ __ ] freak out and there's probably
these aspects where uh that was born in
a certain period of time or like honed
and then you carry it into the other
interfaces or other periods of your life
it's like you're still the same person
it's just like you adapt to situations
right and if you were to again go back
to just like take somebody from a big
company and then put them in a startup
like they will act very differently it's
they're adapting humans are adaptable
right they're trying to figure out how
do I operate inside of a smaller team
faster moving less bureaucracy whatever
and like that's actually like a huge
Advantage we have in the world one way
you've adapted really interestingly is
you've in the past year gone from
hosting the best business show every day
a live stream to now you're it seems
like from the outside looking in you're
doing more interviews more longer style
content and adding a layer of
thoughtfulness I think that's really
interesting to see how did you go about
making that transition so actually uh
the like live stream news show was the
Divergence that was the outlier
um I've always uh for years I've been
very interested in talking to people and
I felt like that was the way that I
learned the the most I read lots of
books I listened to a lot of podcasts uh
and uh I just talk to people and
um since 2018 I've been talking to
people on the podcast uh it was always
longer form so kind of an hour or more
sometimes two three hours uh and it was
just like whatever I wanted to ask right
it was like very little prep
um and I just talked and asked questions
and was curious and it was awesome
um
going into 2021 uh this is like a common
uh challenge mistake and opportunity uh
that I think a lot of people get faced
with it was like this works
do I want to just keep doing the same
thing or do I want to try something else
and it's like an intellectual uh
exercise of like I'm interested in this
I see what other people are doing could
I do it better
um and so we came up a whole plan did it
and I think there was two main takeaways
one was just like I don't really give a
[ __ ] about the news right like like I'm
aware of it I I see it just like
everyone else does but like I don't care
about the day-to-day changes in uh uh
various news stories like all this stuff
it's just like not intellectually very
stimulating for me so
over a 12 month period we did it for 12
months and I'd committed to myself if
I'm going to do it I'm gonna do it for
12 months
um I uh uh just that became obvious to
me like hey I don't really like enjoy
the day-to-day stuff at what point did
that become obvious to you oh probably
like five six months into it uh because
like part of it is like there's like the
honeymoon phase right then there's the
like okay we're like testing all these
different things and then like you start
to realize like hey what is this why
does it feel weird or whatever and then
you realize like it has nothing to do
with the show it has nothing to do with
the the structure of the guests like
it's just like the news right it was a
very different conversation than
um having a conversation with somebody
about like ideas or or uh Frameworks and
things like that so that was one uh and
the second thing is like the news every
single person who works at a news
organization is is screwed right and I
say that from like a loving standpoint
because I'm probably one of the only
people who is a heavy heavy critic of
the mainstream media who's like no I've
done it like I literally went and I did
it on in an independent Manner and I saw
the incentives and the incentive sort of
be crazier say Dumber [ __ ] like uh uh
have uh crazier headlines like like go
for the clicks that's where the [ __ ]
money is right that's where uh the views
are that's where the feedback from the
audience is like it's entertainment and
so
um I was like that's not me right and I
I felt like it got to the point where I
like was becoming this character and I
was just like dude I don't [ __ ] have
to do this [ __ ] right and like
fortunately I was in the position to be
able to do that but it was like okay if
I'm not gonna do this what am I going to
do and I sat and I thought for a long
time and I was like I enjoyed doing what
I've always done like let's just go back
to doing that and by the way like when I
say that I'm not going to do this thing
we're doing right now more there's going
to be some people who love that idea
there's some people some people who hate
it certain people who don't understand
there's gonna be people who say all
kinds of wild crazy [ __ ] whatever and
that's just like I literally don't care
I want to do what I want to do every
single day and like I'm going to go
build my life again in a way that is
structured to do that and that's what I
did so talk to me about those six months
where you have this realization that
this is what you want to do but you
commit it to something you didn't you
don't want to do now yeah it wasn't that
I didn't want to do it it was just like
on a stack rank order like I think a lot
about uh when I was in my teenage years
into my early 20s you do a lot of [ __ ]
you don't want to do but you like know
it's the things that you should do to
get what you want right so you're like
uh I don't know if I could think of um I
did an internship uh uh when I was in
college uh in New York City I was living
in Hoboken uh with a very lovely couple
on Washington Avenue uh like they like
rented out like one of their bedrooms I
don't know what the [ __ ] I was doing how
would I walk down take the path into New
York City uh I was working at the New
York Stock Exchange uh but in the
security division
um I just come back from Iraq and like
somebody I knew knew somebody oh wait so
not Securities security like the VIP
security like make sure that if somebody
tries to ram a truck into the New York
Stock Exchange like we close the [ __ ]
doors and the police were able to kill
them before they get in the building you
were the head bouncer right uh I was uh
the lowest on the totem pole and um my
claim to fame was that they would stick
me with all the people no one to give a
tour of them like hey you you as a
killer you go do that oh and I loved it
I was like oh my God like who are you oh
amazing uh it's like I just like pepper
them with questions and that's probably
like the annoying [ __ ] intern right
um so I was doing that and then I would
go uh because I was playing football in
college all the way up to like I don't
know 45th or 50th Street or something
like when it's like performance centers
and uh I would go and I would work out
after work and then I would come all the
way back down switch over to the path
and go back and I just every single day
for for an entire summer and every
dollar that I made at this internship
which wasn't a lot was basically going
to pay this couple let me live in a
bedroom in their apartment and then pay
for this performance thing and so it got
to this point where like I was like
does who wants to do that nobody [ __ ]
wants to do that but it was super
important because I knew that it was
going to one I was going to meet a lot
of people right which was valuable from
a career standpoint and then two was
like I wanted to go back and and
continue playing football and do all the
stuff so like the performance stuff was
I had to do it and so you look at that
and you're like
the average person probably wouldn't
have wanted to go do all that stuff but
the people who end up finding their way
in life and accomplish some level of
success like they do that type of [ __ ]
that was my experience
um but everyone has that thing of like
oh I did this I did this I did this it
was okay whatever I learned something
like maybe in hindsight I'm thankful for
it uh but you just gotta do [ __ ] you
don't want to do in the beginning
you switch at some point and it becomes
okay now it's not do the things I don't
want to do now maybe I can do things
that like I'm cool with and they're good
for my career they're good for whatever
but at some point you do Transition over
and you're like I literally can do
whatever I want and not from like an
arrogant standpoint but it's like you
develop a skill set like I I recently
was talking to somebody at dinner and I
said to them like tell me a situation
any situation in the world tell me a
country tell me an industry tell me
whatever I can tell you how you could
build a business there now doesn't mean
it's gonna be a great business doesn't
mean that it's going to be something I
would want to do doesn't even mean that
uh I know exactly how to execute it and
not [ __ ] it up or whatever
but once you learn that skill set like
you can go implement this all the time
and so you start to understand it's like
okay like I have choice
and so choice is like very powerful
because I think it actually scares a lot
of people there's a lot of people listen
to this who they could do the same thing
they don't they don't like taking risks
they don't feel confident in themselves
they don't whatever
and then there's the other element of
like if you do take the jump and you do
do it and you and all this stuff like
you just get [ __ ] shot at verbally on
the internet all day long right like
that's not fun
um and so you have to have this like
thick skin as well and so like you got
to understand where you are in life and
there's people who are in their 50s and
60s that I look at and I'm like if I
could ever get the 1 100th of where they
are that would be amazing
and then they're probably looking at me
like if I could have you know uh did
whatever when I was younger like that
had been amazing it's like dude everyone
is [ __ ] looking at everyone else like
what are you doing what are you doing
like just like we got it good like
everyone chill out yeah what do you say
your core competency is your core skill
you mentioned building businesses
anywhere but if that is the answer then
how did you go about building that no
it's just showing up that's literally
the only thing that's the only thing
that I do better than everybody else I
just show up every day
um which sounds so dumb and like uh uh I
don't know [ __ ] Elementary but if you
think about uh take the podcast as an
example uh there's a lot of people who
had podcasts in 2018. Bro you've done
over a thousand episodes like I don't
think people realize what this is
actually like like yeah doing a thousand
of these yeah this is the third one I've
done today I'm not surprised it's
incredible and I did all the other work
right so like when you when you look at
that it's just
um uh why it's because I actually enjoy
it you could not suffer through a
thousand and be like okay I'll just do
it whatever right
um and so I think that like showing up
component is one piece of it the second
thing is I look at a lot of it like a
game so uh I ran
um uh one of the growth teams the
product manager uh for Facebook pages uh
the growth team and like that whole
thing is like there's [ __ ] numbers
and you optimize them and like how many
people click this how many people sign
up here and like everything is just like
a video game but you're playing it with
uh you know tens of millions hundreds of
millions of people who are clicking
different buttons all this stuff uh side
note a lot of bad [ __ ] can happen too
but uh another topic and so if like if
that's like exciting to you then you
like get on social media then you look
at like oh like the finances of a
business oh like uh podcast downloads or
whatever like you just see the game
everywhere and it's like huh I wonder
how many people that walk by that sign
could we increase it by 20 well one
thing we could do is we could add noise
to it like I bet you more people on the
other side of the street would look over
like and you're just like you have a
sickness like this is a [ __ ] sickness
but like I don't have a lot of hobbies I
don't do anything else that's what I do
all day long yeah so you just enjoy it
you mentioned working for Facebook and I
learned recently that you worked closely
with Mark Zuckerberg and Charles
Sandberg what were those meetings like
and what were those people like yeah so
I
let me count you out with like uh uh I
worked on a project
um this is at the end of 2014.
um I uh was asked uh by some folks at
Facebook
um we we had been working on the
Facebook Page's growth uh it had gone
very well uh surprisingly
um in these situations the product
managers probably get too much credit
when things go well and they get too
much [ __ ] when things go wrong
um but I was getting quite a bit of
attention and uh praise for for this
have gone having gone right uh and so I
was basically asked like hey what you
just did over here for all these small
medium-sized businesses like we want to
come and we want to now do it for Mark
and uh Cheryl to their credit they were
like we want to build bigger audiences
on Facebook they were like super based
in hindsight and like very early to like
go direct Trend so this whole idea of
like why do we need to talk to like
reporters or why do we need to go and do
all these other things like we have
Facebook like you know suck at the time
I think had nine million people who were
on his Facebook page he was like I
created this website like Tom from
Myspace has more people on his [ __ ]
profile right like like I want to talk
to the people
so in hindsight like super smart very I
mean we're talking almost a decade ago
right he they were talking about this
um and uh they made one very important
decision that I think uh they'll never
get enough credit for which was they
said we do not want to change the
product to give ourselves an advantage
so there was plenty of ideas that got
floated up by various people around the
company everything from like well when
people sign up for Facebook just make a
Mark's friend that's what Tom from
Myspace did like he hit a hit a big
audience right that feels weird then
there was like an idea about like why
don't we like put up a huge interstitial
one day and it's like a letter from Mark
and there's people in the room like hey
uh you know in other countries like
people do that on like the television
and like they're usually not like super
Democratic you know leaders or whatever
so like one of the beauties of Facebook
is your people from all different walks
of life all these different experiences
and they're all trying to solve this
problem and uh what I learned from uh uh
Market Shaw I give you uh one thing from
each
Cheryl's leadership style was unlike
anything I'd seen before like we walked
in a room uh it was myself her uh and I
think maybe two other people and it was
like hang out with a friend like like
she was just like okay I'm gonna do this
this like what you know whatever and
like meeting's over and you're just like
I don't even feel like I'm at work right
now like we're just hanging out uh but
she was very effective and so in some
way it was like disarming but also
effective which I found uh uh
enthralling and also I was like man I've
never seen somebody do that before
the military leadership schools that
were like do push-ups right the Cheryl
was like a very big difference
Mark
um that we were in a meeting there's
maybe 10 12 people in there and
somebody's giving a presentation it was
like a fairly big product decision that
we were trying to get uh uh his final
decision on and in the middle of the
presentation he stopped he said hey wait
a second go back one slide and he was
like the color of that button or
something was like the shade of blue is
off
huh that's looking like are we getting
punked right now like this can
multi-billionaire who like is obviously
incredibly intelligent is about to make
a like a pretty you know big decision
here and he catches the shade of blue is
not correct
and it was like how do you go from 10
000 feet down to like literally one inch
in in the weeds and then back up to ten
thousand feet and the context switching
I was just blown away so I asked
somebody afterwards uh who had been at
the company for I don't know seven eight
years at that point uh probably yeah six
seven years and um he was like you have
to remember that Mark's been here longer
than everyone else he has more context
he remembers when they chose the shade
of blue they chose right so guess who is
the person most likely to know the shade
of Blue's wrong Mark and he cares about
it because if he lets it slide then lets
it slide again lets it slide again we'll
guess like maybe one day they get
shipped on the website
and so it was just this weird thing of
just like how do you uh uh trust your
team but also be willing to make the big
decisions but also care about the
details and like his ability and range
was uh incredibly impressive to me and
so like you see okay if Cheryl and her
uh uh pros and cons you have Mark his
pros and cons and then you just sort of
realize like oh this is a people
business like they just have the best
people in the world uh at the time
um and uh and they were incredibly
effective so if that's a people business
and you're running a people business
every business of people yes of course
but in particular communication speaking
of people on a day-to-day basis and also
leading people how do you think about
the best leadership style or the
leadership styles you've seen and and
boiling it down to things that you want
to take on and pass on yeah it really
depends uh on the relationship between
people like there's uh there's uh
situations where take a um a passive
minority investor in a business like you
probably should not be uh uh giving tons
of unsolicited advice and like oh I
think think you guys should do this or
like uh um you know here's the thing
that I I know is gonna work you don't
have the context you're not in the
meetings you you don't understand you're
not thinking about as much as they are
like all these different things you're
probably better off just being more of
like a thought provoker have you guys
thought about Acts or uh uh have you
guys talked to this other group that
went through a similar thing I can make
an introduction for you like like you're
more of a facilitator and you're trying
to help them explore as much as possible
but it's not about you it's that you're
not involved there then there's other
situations where like you better make
the decision because if you don't make
the decision this is not getting made
and you've got to live and die with the
decision you make and so like those two
things are very extreme there's
obviously everything in between
but when I think about uh certain types
of businesses uh those businesses desire
or need certain types of leadership so
uh there's like remote work now right
and uh all this remote work stuff is
like awesome like the employees love it
but it takes a very specific type of
leader to be effective in that
environment then uh if you have 1500
employees they're all in person in an
office and like they're like all hands
is Friday I'm gonna be there with like
my beer right like answer my questions
um and so I think that uh it goes back
to this idea of like there's actually no
single leadership style that I think is
good or bad uh it's about what is the
situation who are the people what are
you trying to accomplish and then
there's a leadership style that fits
that and it really just ends up being
like the the measurement of good
leadership is not what the person does
says or it's just like do you get the
job done right and I think
um that is uh lost because we live in a
world where like the leaders get
celebratized
but it's like ultimate like either the
job gets done or it doesn't and I think
like military does a very good job of
just like dude the goal is like
accomplish the mission whatever the
mission is like that's the goal come
hell or high water doesn't matter what
happens like you've accomplished the
mission and part of what I actually
think is interesting is we have now uh
what do we have 20 years essentially 20
years of Iraq and Afghanistan and now
you're starting to see all these stories
come out and people are realizing like
oh [ __ ] uh you know that Medal of Honor
winner or
um you know 13 strong or uh Lone
Survivor or whatever like these usually
are men uh who went through absolute
hell
but they accomplished the mission right
and what I think you're going to see is
you're going to see a ton of these
veterans
um after I think it was World War II it
was like 55 of all Fortune 500 CEOs for
veterans which is like a fascinating
stat because now it's less than like
eight percent right but I don't think
it's gonna necessarily be the CEOs I
think we're gonna see there's a bunch of
these veterans are going to infiltrate
all these different organizations and
they're going to bring some of that
Tempo with them and if you go back like
what's the single most effective
organization in the world it's the
military right and so like uh that's
true in the United States and elsewhere
and so I think you're going to start to
see a lot of these like leadership
tactics I think you're going to see a
lot of the day-to-day uh things that
people learn start to infiltrate into
organizations
um but the one thing that is the threat
to it is are people willing to work like
we're pretty soft as a country now like
very soft so on that point what can
people do to if they don't have a
military background to get some of the
advantages that being in the military
gives It ultimately the military only
you really like three things right it's
like shoot move and communicate which is
uh if you think of uh teamwork like
that's all that is right it's like how
do you and other people go and do
something together and not kill each
other not get hurt uh and accomplish the
mission
it's teamwork right like that's like a
pretty basic [ __ ] thing they have all
kinds of cool names they have literally
books that are written that are super
long but it's like they teach you
teamwork uh second is leadership so
there's somebody who's in charge of that
uh and they're somebody who's in charge
of that person who's in charge of that
person like there's a whole hierarchical
structure it's like teamwork leadership
and then the third thing is just like a
a mental toughness thing and I actually
think uh in reverse order it's easier to
learn the mental toughness than it is
the Teamwork because the mental
toughness thing is reliant on you you
don't need other people to learn it uh
the leadership thing you can actually
become a better leader even if other
people aren't around you can read books
you can talk to people who are leaders
you can listen to podcasts like like
there's a way to kind of sharpen your
mind a little bit or your tactics the
teamwork is where you are relying on a
ton of other people and teamwork is this
weird thing where uh you only get good
teamwork one of two ways either there's
like a special moment in time where some
people come together they're rallied
around a single Mission and like it just
works and like there's some like
fortunate you know uh kind of alignment
there or two is it's forged by things
like the military where uh you just get
beat into people's [ __ ] head like
there's a reason why um I always use the
example in basic training
um when you carry the cups in the chow
hall
you carry it with your elbows up at a 90
degree angle to the cup like I look like
a [ __ ] idiot right like why are we
all walking around like literally it's
almost like you're walking around
looking like a duck or something right
you're like why are we doing this and
like I don't know six eight weeks into
it all sudden you go to the grenade
range and guess what that's the same
position that you hold a grenade to pull
the pin wow and so they've literally
ingrained it into you for weeks and
weeks three times a day every day for
weeks
to hold that position and now all of a
sudden it's like second nature wow and
so you realize like yeah there's a bunch
of dumb [ __ ] but also there's like some
intentionality to it and uh why is it
important to pull it that way like damn
wouldn't it be bad if you were standing
next to somebody and you pulled the pin
and [ __ ] couldn't throw it and now
you're holding it yeah now you just put
your friend in danger right it's like
there's all these little things like
that uh which you can't recreate like I
don't think that we should try to
recreate it all it's just like hey it is
what it is one thing that I take from
that is that there's no wasted moments
right and it's something that when I was
studying you in preparation for this I
noticed that scares the [ __ ] out of me
it's studying me yeah well I listened to
about 10 podcasts to do research for
this and I'm noticing the common theme
of you not wasting moments I was
listening to you and David Burrell today
talk about how you in I believe 2020 how
you described it was you would take an
hour and you'd be like okay what can
this hour be dedicated to and that's
like no wasted moments like all right
next hour what can that hour be
dedicated to in terms of content how
have you used that to create content
that idea of no wasted moments so just
on the topic in general uh
again I got a sickness I can't like I I
can't be bored like literally if you
were to talk to my wife like if we're
sitting there and I'm sitting for like
two three minutes I'm like all right I
gotta like okay there's an interview I
could watch I'll read this book I'll
like do something whatever and it's not
always like high production right
there's times where I [ __ ] Doom
scroll or whatever
um but but uh that is not healthy by any
means
um but it is uh enjoyable for me in some
weird way and so I I think that that
ends up uh um being something to
capitalize on right it's like we have
the opportunity to get so much more
information and I really enjoy uh doing
that in terms of the content
um I would say that there's two like
aspects to it the first is uh when 2020
happened uh there's a lot of people like
oh [ __ ] like I can't do interviews in
person whatever
yo I know they're not busy they ain't
got [ __ ] going on right now no one got
[ __ ] going on I just started emailing
everybody and I was like let's do a
podcast let's do a podcast let's do a
podcast and like you can see it in the
responses like people who would like not
answer before or who were like oh I'm
busy like let's let's uh maybe do it at
the beginning of next year or whatever
they're like okay and they were doing in
their kitchens in their living rooms
they were doing off their [ __ ] phones
like it didn't matter and so I was just
like oh guess what not only are the
guests not doing anything the audience
isn't doing anything either they're
locked at home as well they're not doing
[ __ ] work right they're just watching
YouTube they're listening to things
whatever uh and so I was just like
there's a moment in time hit the gas and
I think a lot about I didn't know this
at the time but in hindsight I've had
friends through discussion uh highlight
the fact of like sometimes you gotta
know like hey we're just we're going the
speed limit and then there's some times
where you're like dude you just gotta
hit the hole man like just [ __ ] slam
on the gas and you got two months go and
it's you got to learn it's acquired
skill of knowing when to go and when to
kind of just okay we're doing well
um but that was one of those moments
where it was just go and I record a
couple podcasts that exploded right and
uh chamoth was the big one
um and it was the first time I had
recorded a conversation that did a
million views on YouTube and I remember
recording conversation I walked away and
I was just like I didn't even think
about the audience I was like holy [ __ ]
I just got like a [ __ ] master class
in what is happening
um that was cool and like
if I hadn't been so OCD about like
actually publishing I might have forgot
to publish it like it was just like such
a valuable conversation in hindsight
like that's why it was so popular was
because it was so valuable to me so the
audience found it valuable and so then
it became a game of like all right well
if we record for an hour how many pieces
of content can we get out of it and like
now we're like Elite level compared to
how we used to be
um but it's like okay if I record a
conversation I get an audio podcast I
get a YouTube video I probably get some
YouTube clips now I can get shorts reels
tick tocks like all this stuff then I
could actually take it and I could write
a whole uh email out of it and I could
send that right and you start to like
play this game you're like I get like 10
or 12 pieces of content out of this that
was really only an hour hour and a half
of my time you know uh back then and so
when you start to learn that game you
just realize that like just do it you do
it put it all out there and then the
audience tells you what works and what
doesn't work and so many people I think
uh they get discouraged early on but
like our podcast literally I went back
and looked a couple months ago guess how
many downloads we got in the first like
six months
we're getting like 250 a day 300 you
know on a per episode or whatever like
we should have stopped like we were
insane to keep going but it was just
like I didn't even know how to check the
analytics right like literally somebody
else was doing I didn't even know how to
do that so I was just like I had a great
conversation somebody else said they'll
come in okay do that like keep going and
then when I start like oh there's
download numbers and like all this stuff
and I was like all right wow Google how
do people grow a podcast right okay how
do they do like and you start to play
the game and the next thing you know
you're like this is just work like just
do the work and it will grow and that's
what happened
it's it's really interesting to hear you
talk about it like that when you spoke
to Patrick O'Shaughnessy on invest like
the best you said four things to look
for in Founders were persistence empathy
communication and salesmanship that was
in 2018 and I'm curious if you would
still agree with that what I say
persistence what persistence empathy
yeah communication and salesmanship yeah
I generally still agree with that that I
probably would like change up the way I
described them but like basically don't
quit right I
I won't say names obviously but uh we've
had a number of companies that we were
really excited about we're doing well uh
or even companies that weren't doing
well and like people just quit like you
can hey this didn't work this wouldn't
like you just quit right uh I still had
money in the bank still like could have
kept going and it's some people were
like honest they're like hey I'm burnt
out like this just isn't for me uh other
people were like ah you know and then
you're just like where did that person
go how do you take that as somebody
whose core competency is not stopping
you can't change other people right like
it's kind of like advice like everyone
wants to give people advice and what you
realize is the only people who are going
to follow any advice are the people who
show up and they're like hey I want to
do this like what should I do yeah right
um and we can talk to a bunch of
examples of that so I would say
persistence is like definitely the thing
um it's probably the most important
thing outside of idea market and like
who's actually on the team it's just
like are these people gonna quit or not
because this shit's hard it's super long
uh it can be very very lonely uh and
there's an ego element to it of like uh
what's the joke everyone says their
startup Founder's just unemployed right
of like like uh you know especially when
they're starting out they're like yeah
me and my friend we are working in a
closet and we have a company you know
like yes but at some point like they
look around the room and they're like
are we just two weirdos in a closet or
like do we actually have a company right
um and like that's healthy actually
right that's not a bad thing it it's uh
it's part of figuring out hey what is
the product we're building so I think
person is really big uh the salesmanship
and like
communication skills I would actually
put those in the same bucket it's just
like
can you raise money can you hire people
can you sell that's the same skill set
right can you tell stories can you get
people excited to want to do things and
like join you on this journey uh if you
can't raise money you're never going to
be able to recruit people you're never
going to be able to sell um right if you
can't sell very well you're probably
gonna struggle with the other two so
it's this ability to like can you
basically just bend the world to do [ __ ]
that you need which you can call
salesmanship you can call communication
skills you can call it whatever you want
but just like how how do you do that and
there's not like a formula it's not like
okay here uh fill out these three
questions and I'll node can you do that
or not I think you have to see people in
action and some of it is like you
talking to them but some of it's also uh
how they interact with other people what
have they done previously like there's
all these little tells that I think you
can get at that
and then probably saying I've changed my
mind on is like the idea actually really
[ __ ] matters and the market really
matters and so those are less about like
the founder as much as like is this
Foundry a good decision maker and the
decision making that you can tell
immediately is just what idea are they
choosing to pursue like they're gonna
invest their most valuable asset which
is their time what are they going to
spend time on uh and then two is how big
is the market and and
good Founders won't go after horrible
markets because they either if it
appears to be a small Market they have
some belief that it's going to be bigger
in the future it's going to change so
they can you know do something that will
expand the market uh or two is somebody
who you think is a good founder but
picked a really bad market usually what
ends up happening is uh it doesn't work
out no matter how good you think the
founder is I think it's Andreessen has a
saying uh bad team meets good market
market wins good team meets bad market
market wins and so uh kind of the first
test of like are you a good decision
maker what idea do you choose to work on
and how big is the market you're going
after and that tells you a lot about can
this person continuously make good
decisions or not
and how do you think about
if you're investing in companies how
important is
the person's social media or having an
audience online when investing in
companies who cares yeah yeah like like
I mean if you're in a business where
that is an advantage great uh but I
don't know take all the millionaires in
America like how many of them have big
social media following it's like point
one percent of them right uh and sure
social media wasn't invented when they
got rich and like whatever uh but like
to be a good real estate investor you
don't need to be on [ __ ] Twitter
right now it can help if you want to
raise money on Twitter if you want to
meet other people like there's
advantages to it but this idea that like
you have to have a big audience I think
is like completely ridiculous
um and uh I also think that uh it can
actually hurt right so there's the joke
that like there's an inverse uh uh
relationship between the amount of
tweets and the work that gets done and
like I've seen it in my life like when
I'm tweeting lessons because I'm getting
more [ __ ] done right if I'm sitting on
Twitter all day long like I'm not
getting [ __ ] done you have 66 000 tweets
I believe yeah there's a lot of [ __ ]
wasted time right
um most of those nice I'm just replying
to people uh I I don't know um but like
if you think Jesus Christ 66 000 yeah
holy [ __ ] but you're actually such a
[ __ ] loser
you've built something amazing and yeah
it's valuable to it to an extent but
like there is a diminishing return as
well right so like what's the difference
between uh a million followers 1.6 and 2
million like it probably doesn't [ __ ]
matter uh you know if you have like a
stupid brain like me and you're like oh
my God how do I like move the number
right yeah but at some point you're just
like I don't care anymore and like now
people might notice I tweet way less
some of it's like it's just tiring to
deal with all the trolls and there are
people just being stupid on the internet
two is like I've replaced a lot of the
tweeting with like I'm actually really
active in like some private group chats
and stuff where I get a ton of value out
of so like that's just like a zero sum
hey one minute on Twitter is now one
minute in like a private group chat uh
and then another thing is just like I
kind of feel like I got most of the
value out of uh from like no audience to
having an audience
um
you know what's the point yeah what your
big talking point recently is like get
off the internet and spend some time in
real life I've noticed that it well it's
um Bear markers are very good
clearing your brain right when you see
the number go down yeah well it it ends
up being this weird thing where
um
the people who look at numbers going up
tend to also be the people who look at
the numbers going down right and I think
I'm unique in that like I [ __ ] love
more than anyone else when that number
goes up right you're like this is
awesome like nothing is more fun than
winning right like all this stuff
um and that's just human nature like I
don't care how uh uh gentlemanly you
want to present yourself or whatever
like if somebody texts you and they're
like yo
the stock you own the bond the real
estate whatever went up a lot you go to
your computer and you look and you're
like wow that was cool right
um but some portion of people also go
and they're obsessed when it goes down
right I'm not like that fortunately so
like I'm super calm uh in like bear
Market stuff like I just don't care
enough because I'm not gonna do anything
no matter Bitcoin could go to a thousand
dollars other assets I own could
literally go to pennies I'm not gonna do
anything different so like why do I look
right I I just don't waste the time
um but the second thing is uh I had a
scare uh uh fortunately it was a stupid
scare but it was a scare in that uh five
or six months now uh ago I went to read
a physical book somebody gave me a book
and I was like oh look at this this
antique here this physical thing and I
sat down and tried to read it and I
couldn't read
and I was like what is going on my head
hurt my eyes hurt I couldn't concentrate
I like could not read the book I could
read the words like I did not lose the
ability to read but like I literally
could not concentrate read and I was
like what the [ __ ] is going on so I
started at Google and uh there's a
couple of things that were interesting
one it was just like everyone's addicted
to the internet and our phones and like
that reinforcing like God I feel so
stupid like yes that's probably true uh
the second thing was uh there's some
scientific studies that are coming out
that like because we look at screens all
day our phones or our computers they
stay pretty much within like three or
four feet of our faces we never look
with depth and so like it actually
messes with your eyes
um so then I was like well how do I go
outside like where is the farthest thing
that I can look at right like like
you're sure like oh [ __ ] this is bad and
so I just said to myself I was like I am
going to read physical books and like it
sucked I'm I feel like such a loser for
saying like oh reading physical books
was hard but like my head hurt my eyes
hurt like it was hard so I've said to
some friends like hey go get a physical
book try to sit down and read for an
hour most of you listen to this cannot
do that wow and you're just like that's
a crazy thing now I love audiobooks you
can put speed it up all the stuff
Kindle's great whatever but I said to
myself I'm gonna read the physical books
because like I want to prove to myself I
could do it and so uh the beauty of
physical book is it is not a screen you
cannot be on the internet and read the
book at the same time now if you're
really bad and undisciplined you can
like read the book and every page turn
to look at your phone which I definitely
have done
um but like it does pull you off and
then what you realize is like
dude if you read Twitter I think I
tweeted one time like if you read
Twitter every day you think the world is
ending yeah like literally the world is
going to blow up we're all gonna die and
like you know the evil people are gonna
take over and it's like sure like some
of that [ __ ] may happen or may not uh
but there is this like calming effect of
like just get off the internet and uh
what I found is that like the first time
you try to do it even for like I don't
know an afternoon
it's hard like another test is uh read a
physical book for an hour another one is
uh can you at noon put your phone down
and leave and come back at dinner no
watch no phone no anything you will
literally be like like we're addicted to
this [ __ ] right it's like oh my God
what's the notification what's going on
like you just freak out and so uh you
have to like wean yourself off which
sounds crazy but like we are addicted
and so you have to treat it like an
addiction uh by the way that doesn't
mean that I don't spend an hour on
Twitter right and still Doom scroll it
just means that uh I have the ability to
not go on Twitter if I don't want to
um
and like there's some like victory in
that I don't know it's like a weird
thing that I'm just like slowly working
through that uh I'm enjoying reading the
physical books uh but it's way slower
like I'm like I read for like two hours
at night and I'm literally like holy
[ __ ] I only read 50 pages you know or
whatever I'm like I literally am the
slowest reader in the world the
audiobook would be done by now well your
wife recently came out with a new book
or released the the pre-order which I
ordered right away and I'm super excited
about it
what's that like when your significant
other is is writing a book and you get
to witness that process yeah uh
I know everywhere in the book she read
me every single page sometimes no matter
how tired I was or whatever she was like
sit down and listen no wonder why you
started reading yeah well well it it um
uh it was very cool because I think uh I
knew Plano always wanted to write a book
um and uh when our daughter was born it
was kind of this moment of like when
else are you gonna do it right
um and I think from the outside people
were like what do you mean like you have
a a newborn baby uh you're you're still
uh running your business and you're
gonna write this book or whatever and
she was like yeah I'm gonna do it and
like to her credit like people are like
oh Palm probably like you know took the
baby every day or whatever like no like
we very much like we enjoy hanging out
with our daughter and spending time and
stuff there's like maybe two or three
times where I was like
hey I know you've got to like finish for
a deadline or something like that like
I'll go hang out with the baby by myself
which the first couple times like scary
[ __ ] oh okay because you're like so
scared you're gonna do something wrong
um but uh other than that like it was
very much as she calls like edges of
time babies asleep we're both working or
whatever
um and so it was awesome to like see it
come together and then like when she
would read it to me I like
I should kill me I really didn't want to
like it you didn't no I mean I'm joking
right but I wanted to kind of be like uh
yeah it's okay you know whatever I kind
of give her a little bit of [ __ ] but I
remember every time she read me like
damn this is a good book right like this
is something that I would enjoy reading
if I didn't know who you were uh it was
like chapter after chapter after chapter
and I was like
are you about to write like a [ __ ]
amazing book and uh when it was all said
and done I was like you know again you
never know with the internet like
sometimes things they [ __ ] take off
sometimes they don't like the internet
is this weird thing
um but I think it's a book that she's
proud of and also I think it's a book
that like when I read it I learn
something which I believe will be other
people will learn something
um and then when you look at it it's
also got the ability to like teach you a
high level idea but it's also very
specific right so it's like here's this
idea by the way example example example
example which uh the books that I don't
enjoy they're just super high level they
don't have the specificity to them so uh
we'll see we'll we'll see how it uh how
it goes but I'm very proud of her and uh
uh she did something I couldn't have
done uh which like is even cooler
because I think people are like oh he
like works really hard like all stuff
and I'm like dude y'all think me like
this is [ __ ] crazy what she just did
so uh it's cool to see people are
excited about it and then what's what's
going on with you guys both putting out
content and how has that shaped you I
mean personally my parents are they work
together every day and and they
it's interesting because people say like
how could you do that how could you work
so closely with your significant other
and it seems like you guys see each
other all the time and see each other
online all the time so you're doing the
modern day version of working together
see each other on the internet
uh actually a great test would be like
do we text or Twitter DM each other more
often right I don't know
um no but uh
yeah it's just very enjoyable like I
have this theory in relationships that
last uh there's only two ways that a
relationship can last you meet
relatively Young And as you kind of go
through those different uh periods of
your life you both evolve and change
together and it's either because uh you
know there's like true love whatever
People wrap their heads around that uh
there is
um some defined like Mission like hey we
both really care about X and so uh as we
both evolve as uh uh people are single
than dating then married with kids like
whatever that mission like Keeps Us
United or whatever
um but there's like very much meet early
and and uh continue the second thing is
like you've been out on your own and you
have the ability to like okay I kind of
like am comfortable with myself and then
you meet somebody and you're like oh we
get along really well and it's more of
like um this person's like your best
friend to some degree and uh therefore
like it works
what's crazy is society actually focuses
on like this Middle Ground which is like
oh uh don't get married at 18 or 20. you
don't have kids then like what's your 23
right and like I grew up in North
Carolina there's a lot of people get
married 23 24 25 26 years old and
I would have been a complete [ __ ] if
I got married then right and like Flynn
and I have talked about it like
if you met I don't know maybe Post 25
years old your significant other and you
both sat down ask yourselves like would
you have liked me in high school right
and like I don't think planet and I like
we joke all the time like I don't know
like 50 50. yeah and so
it's actually better that like we met
when we did uh and it's this crazy thing
where like there's no difference between
work and life and like like it's just
like we get to do what we want to do
every day which is awesome uh but like
guess what the conversation at dinner is
I read this thing I saw this thing did
you watch this oh I listened to this
thing like what'd you think about this
idea do you agree do you not agree
whatever it's like a cheat code like how
many people get to do that not that many
so it's cool yeah one thing you guys
have talked about is that the two things
that make for good conversations is
something you've spoken about and it's
people who don't do small talk and
people who ask a lot of questions
you want me put one of my friends on uh
expose one of my friends so uh uh Mateo
the CEO of uh he's gonna kill me
um he he doesn't Chit Chat he he's not
he doesn't have a chit chat bone in his
body so we joke with him all the time
and say he's Mr Chit Chat because if he
says hello
uh but like one of my best friends uh we
talk all the time and it's just like
and like that's just what we enjoy doing
we're super efficient we we enjoyed
talking about these different things
um and so like
you know it when you see it like there's
dinners that you'll go to and people
spend time talking about other people or
like just like [ __ ] and you like
leave and you're just like that was fun
but like I didn't really learn anything
I didn't like I don't think I
contributed value and I don't think I
got value out of the conversation more
so than it was like entertaining the
equivalent of watching the news yeah
watching the news or just like Doom
scrolling or what like whatever it is
right it's like I did spend the time
there uh I was present but like that was
weird then when there's the like no
[ __ ] no Chit Chat whatever uh I I
joke that like when me playing on Mateo
and Alex go to dinner we should have an
agenda like like literally like like
it's at that point now and we're just
mow through [ __ ] but like I'm like on
Thursday night like yo Saturday night I
gotta go to dinner with my friends and
like we're gonna we're gonna hang right
and I'm like looking forward to because
it's fun but it it's this type of thing
where like I'm like I don't care if
we're here for five hours I don't want
to leave because it's instantly
stimulating and learning is fun it's
like all these different things and when
you find groups of people who all like
similar things and are willing to like
be honest with each other that's the
other thing is like in The Superficial
conversations everyone just says what
they think people want to hear but like
if you're like actually honest with
people like you may be like I like X I
don't know if I was like you're dumb I
like why and if you can like have that
conversation not be offended like you're
way ahead of everyone else because
superficial conversations like you know
it's like oh yeah I like X and Y you
know it's nice uh okay do you want to
order okay no you order no I'll order
like like it's just like okay Mateo
you're ordering this like go and it's
way better that way
how do you find friends like that
you have to hire and fire friends right
like there's a group of people that I
would say plin and I will always be
friends with regardless
um I'm very fortunate I've got a large
family my brothers and parents and
everything and so like you you uh uh
there's certain things like no matter
what you do in life what your interests
are how you evolve whatever like that
like they're good they're in the circle
right
um but then there's also friends who
like I've been fired by friends who
they're like hey man I don't really give
a [ __ ] about any of this stuff like like
I want to go spend my time doing this I
know you don't like it so like don't
worry like it's not like I won't be
offended but like I'm gonna go do this
awesome and then like next you know like
two years later you're like I haven't
talked to that person in six months
right and okay that's fine right because
they're happy and I'm happy uh but also
like you kind of know like you just like
see someone out in the world and you're
like I bet you that person would be uh
they could be in the club and like go to
dinner or get lunch or meet or talk or
whatever and you're like okay that was
cool like like whatever and it's like
you end up like hiring a friend and I
think people hate that because it's like
so clinical right now I'm not like hey
here's a job offer like do you want to
be my friend but to a degree uh it is
very much like no what do you do at a
business like the people who are
productive they end up getting more
responsibility they take on more things
like they stay around like all the stuff
the people who are not productive or are
anti-productive like they don't last
very long
why not treat your conversations right
again it's like you're investing time
what's the return you're getting for
your time invested by the way you can
literally go to dinner and be like I get
no professional uh value out of this
anything it's just like I enjoy going to
dinner because this person is hilarious
and they make me laugh
perfect right so it's not a judgment on
like everything has to be like work or
business or whatever but like
that dinner is my hobby right most
people are like oh I have this hobby I
go and I do XYZ and I'm like no like I
go to [ __ ] intellectual war with
people and I love it and so do they and
like we're losers but like but we enjoy
doing it yeah definitely not losers and
there's a quote that sticks out which is
the master in The Art of Living draws a
little distinction between his work and
his play and that is something I feel
like you live so so truthfully yeah well
I believe that most people uh that I
talk to and I'm like oh that person's
happy which is like a weird concept
um
they've they just live and breathe what
they do and do is what they live and
what they where they work or whatever
um and so uh uh Daniel gross and Tyler
Cohen wrote a book recently uh called
talent and one of the questions is uh
that they ask people is like what do you
do on the weekends and uh their point is
um your personality is revealed on the
weekends and so their point uh in that
statement is like if you're the type of
person who was saying uh you go to
college and you're like I want to be an
Olympic track athlete and then you said
to your friends I'm not going to go
party tonight because I have track
practice in the morning I'm not going to
go and get ice cream because I eat
healthy because I want to be an Olympian
right people be like duh right like no
[ __ ] like I don't think you can eat ice
cream smoke weed party and then like go
run you know the 100 meter dash and win
and break the world record right uh but
somehow the people who want to
accomplish something that isn't physical
like athlete level stuff uh we don't
necessarily treat it that way it's like
very weird and so
um I think that that should be like okay
because you then are like no this is who
I am this is what I like doing and like
just go do it right and then now your
work and your life become the same thing
and to some degree uh I'm confused by
people who like could go to work nine to
five and at five o'clock be like okay
see you guys I'll be back at nine
o'clock tomorrow and then like literally
they don't think about work until not
like I am so jealous that sounds amazing
I can't do that when did you realize
that your work and play were combined
was that the moment you feel like you
made it
oh it I don't think it's ever like done
right it's just
uh it works in Reverse it's like once
you get comfortable betting on yourself
like that's the that's the key thing is
you have to be willing to bet on
yourself
um and once you once you know like okay
cool I'm comfortable doing this
um then you're just like what am I
interested in and like how do I get to
do more of that a day um right like
that's pretty much all it is uh but the
big like
moment or crossover is like are you
willing to bet on yourself right uh
we could talk about uh there's a lot of
journalists right now at the mainstream
media Outlets they don't want to work
there anymore
they all put on the face right it's like
they put on like the costume and they're
like going to work oh yeah so make sure
media is amazing on television here let
me write the article yes it's awesome
look at my business card it's great I
talk to these people like I see tweeting
on Twitter and I'm like I literally had
a [ __ ] conversation with you two days
ago and you're like I can't wait to get
out of this place and the reason is
because they see the Independent Media
stuff they see substance they see
YouTube they see podcasts like that's
their world right they they aspired to
get to a point where they could create
content in whatever form factor uh they
wanted to talk to audiences they wanted
to be on television they wanted to meet
people like whatever the thing is that
got them there
but they are scared shitless of walking
out the door and having to bet on
themselves and the reason is because if
they fail they're like damn I gave that
up
and it and it's like human nature right
and so some people are like I don't care
like I'll come right back right like who
cares like go other people are like I
have to plot out every single day you
ever talk to like a 22 year old like oh
yeah 24 I would do this at 26 I'll do
this at 28 I'll do this and at 30 I'll
do this and I'm like no you're [ __ ]
not like literally like point one
percent of people do that stuff right
and actually execute on so I think that
there's this thing of like
there's never been a time in human
history where people in content creation
which like in the most watered down
versions what journalism is they're
creating content on the Internet it's
all competition for eyeballs
um can bet on themselves and do it
independently now there's a lot of
people who say like oh I don't want to
be an entrepreneur I don't want to do
marketing I don't do customer service I
don't want to do this whatever cool like
that's fine but if you know that about
yourself like then that that's one thing
uh but then there's another group of
people who are like ah I love that idea
do you think it could work right like
people answer my emails because of at
whatever.com or do they answer it
because of the part before the at
whatever.com
and like you want to have a humbling
[ __ ] experience answer that question
right and like I can say that planet has
talked about it publicly before when she
was leaving fortune that was the
question do people
respond because it's Paulina or they
respond because it's fortune.com
we didn't know we had no clue and so we
did everything we could to mitigate the
risk or whatever right she worked her
ass off to put herself in a position to
be able to go bet on herself and then
one day she was like let's do it like
she's like I'm gonna do it and I
remember being like
come again like are you really gonna do
it right and uh she was like yeah
and she left and it was just so obvious
like literally within 48 Hours like duh
of course this was gonna work right
um and so I think that it it's like you
essentially are like putting yourself up
for judgment
and you have to be intellectually honest
with yourself because if you're not
intellectually honest with yourself the
market will be
and like that just scares people
what advice would you have for some some
journalist who
doesn't know if they want to bet on
themselves or what was that conversation
like is there anything you could say to
push them over the edge or it's more so
like if you have it inside of you it'll
work out oh I could convince all of them
to quit like that's the other thing is
once you get like decent at the
recruiting game and like understanding
okay you don't like working here because
a b and c thing I can push on this and I
can and you could like get very good at
recruiting
um do you view that as your role now as
a recruiter for Independence not for
Independence just like a lot of the time
I spend is I'm trying to find
interesting people to talk to
essentially interviewing them right uh
and then also uh in terms of making sure
our companies have the best talent
working there so I don't want to try to
find interesting people right interview
whatever
um and uh so you almost like um
you ever seen like uh there's these
viral videos that happen where like a
cop with like literally a gun on his
side all of a sudden is like boxing
somebody on like the side of the road
they're like in a fist fight and then
like the comments are always like yo
matter respect for the cop like he had
the gun but he never pulled it right
like he he stood there and he like went
toe-to-toe whatever like I kind of feel
like that's where uh everybody I respect
that's really really good at acquiring
Talent
they don't actually try to convince
people to join them what they end up
doing is they know the people who will
be successful or the people who like end
up banging on the door and they're like
yo I gotta do this the way they do it is
that they're super good selling the
mission or the importance or like like
they're definitely are participating in
the process but what they don't do is
they don't try to get somebody to do
something that they're gonna regret six
months later because it just causes
bigger problems and so it's like very
fascinating how uh in some way the
counter-intuitive recruiting aspect
Works where uh you know there's a
there's a company
um there's a couple here in Miami called
traba uh it's a good example so uh uh
this guy Mike runs it and
um if you go to their like careers page
90 of people are like these people are
nuts I'm not working there
what type of company is it uh they have
a Marketplace that's like replacing like
temp agencies so uh they help
um if you right now drive on Uber do a
food delivery tax grab it whatever
there's another option so kind of gig
economy style work uh but what they do
is they uh maybe there's temp work
needed at a warehouse for a day or two
maybe it's to set up for a concert maybe
it's like unarmed security at a
conference or with like the yellow
shirts or whatever so it's uh all these
like temp worker type opportunities but
you can get paid 15 16 17 18 19 20 an
hour right so so it's like similar type
of Engagement with a platform where
you're getting hired to do work that
you're not actually an employee but it
could be something you enjoy more or a
higher pay or whatever
six days a week they work
not five six days a week in the office
9 A.M to 9 pm
90 of people don't want to do that [ __ ]
like yo [ __ ] that I'm too successful I'm
this I'm that I I I want to do this
whatever they don't judge any of those
people right and I've talked to them a
lot about it a lot there's people who
are like I can't do it I have a kid
he says fine that you should go spend
time with your kid right like that's
actually the thing that you should go do
this isn't for you it doesn't mean
you're bad doesn't mean we're bad it
just means like not a match
but then there's somebody who was like I
got a kid but I [ __ ] love this right
like that's what I'm looking for and so
uh in some ways it's like the Navy Seals
uh Navy Seals pitch where uh what do
they say they say we have a high
attrition rate you should not do this
it's hard like whatever and like there's
some crazies that show up and they're
like I could do that [ __ ] like I love
that right and so uh the pitch sometimes
by saying what it who it isn't for
actually attracts the right people yeah
and so like you just learn these like
tricks over time and you're and I'm like
blown away when I've like figured some
of this stuff out I'm like wow there is
like levels to this game well you were
saying that in the workshop you did with
David perel you said don't create
content like it's hard you shouldn't do
it like this is a mistake and then
that's selecting for the type of people
who are actually going to look at that
challenge and be like I could do that
it's because all the advice that people
get everyone gets like pushed to do
things in today's society right uh and
it's like a weird I don't know I feel
like a [ __ ] Grandpa like today's
society but
um everyone is pushed to do things he's
like you can do anything you can do
anything like technically you can do
every uh anything but you shouldn't try
everything right and that's okay like we
that is perfectly fine
but I think that people sometimes do a
disservice to Folks by being like it's
all Rosy like actually if you tell them
all the [ __ ] that sucks and they still
want to do it
way more likely and you know I'll uh uh
I'll give my brother [ __ ] only because I
said this before
um he's working at a bank in uh July of
2020 and he called me up uh and he goes
um I want to talk to you about something
can I come see you
sure whatever like you know what dumb
thing are we gonna talk about right and
uh uh and he can't it was funny because
he was like
very serious right and he was like I
wanna I wanna do uh essentially content
on the internet but it didn't say that
way and I was like
oh you're not gonna do it and he was
like no no I'm serious like I created a
sub stack and I was like what and he had
a brand already in this and like and I
was like
what are you gonna do like okay great
congratulations you spent like two hours
right what are you gonna do and
I wasn't convinced until like maybe four
or six weeks into it every single
morning before he went to work at that
bank he got up at like 4 30 in the
morning and he wrote the [ __ ] email
and he sent it and then he went to work
and then while he was at work he would
like go to the bathroom and like tweet
and then like come back work go like he
was doing all this stuff and I was like
this psycho was really about to do this
like like he is committed to doing it
and so that's when I was like all right
how like what do you want to do and
literally we came up with a couple of
milestones we say if you hit these three
Milestones like you should quit yeah and
he was like really like it was kind of
this moment of like did my brother's
time I should quit my job and I was like
yeah I think like that's real like this
would be like product Market fit
essentially and uh to his credit the day
that he hit the Milestones he quit wow
and uh you know he
um uh I don't know if he's ever said
this uh somebody he worked with uh who
will go uh nameless was like it remember
it's a bank right like you're gonna go
be a writer on the internet and they
were like they were so confused but like
to his credit he was willing to bet on
himself he was willing to have the
confidence to be like yo I want to do
this like this is what I enjoy doing let
me go do it
um and so just the reason I tell that
story is like I probably told 50 to 100
people like without exaggeration 50 to
100 people I talked to over the years
where they were like I would like to do
some of this stuff and I was like okay
write every day do this whatever no no
zero of them did it the very first
person I ever saw do it was my brother
and I was like damn like I was shocked
but I was excited and like now look at
him you just started that story by
saying I'm gonna give my brother some
[ __ ] and you just come continue to Hype
him up for the next well it's because I
probably told some stuff he's like dude
come on but uh what what were the Miles
by the way that's also a way to give
your brother [ __ ] is he not saying
anything bad because now he's like oh
damn like I can't I can't come at him
next time because he was nice to me so
what were some of those milestones and
what exactly was the advice uh I don't
know how companies with like the exact
Milestones uh one of them was a uh like
an ad Revenue uh Milestone uh and then
another one was um I forget the actual
number uh but it was uh how many people
were subscribed to the email right and
so it's just like can you go from zero
he had no Twitter account he had no
email he basically
wasn't on the internet right like in the
sense we think about from like a Content
standpoint
um he he I think maybe had like a
private Instagram or something right uh
and like I would put him in the category
of like he was like the average mid-20s
person on the internet who's like I
consume all this but I don't really
create anything and he went very quickly
to like oh now he has Twitter followers
oh now he's got his people subscribed to
the email oh we can get advertisers that
want to actually like uh sell against
this content and so then it was just
like all right you hit the Milestones
but like
it's on you right like I didn't help him
right in terms of we didn't sell any ads
for we didn't do any of that [ __ ] like
it was definitely on him because it also
is very clear that like
um I've had people come to me and be
like Oh but like you you could like help
me grow my email list you could have
sell the ads you could do like yes we
could do all that [ __ ] but like why
would we do it for you right like we
should do it for ourselves which is
greedy as [ __ ] and like super selfish
but it's actually if I did it for you
it'd be a disservice because at some
point you're gonna you're gonna grow big
enough where you're gonna be like I want
to leave and I want to do it on my own
and if you don't know how to do that
[ __ ] like you are screwed and what
you've seen is a lot of people who have
gotten really big at some of these
organizational stuff they do leave very
few of them have been successful or as
successful when they've left because
they don't realize what's wrapped around
them and so it's kind of this like look
just like die early if you're gonna die
right like just get it over with and if
you kind of pass that attrition you know
or kind of past that difficulty stage
then you're good to go I want to go back
to thinking of you mentioned before
about how some people have their careers
lined up of like 24 I'm going to do this
27 I'm going to do this third and I
think that goes and hits that the way
education is in America today at least
where it's like all right at 18 you're
going to do this and and then you're
gonna go to college and then you're
going to get a job and it's like
everything is very much given to us and
the path is very much given to us
what if anything can we do to reform
that system or to change the way people
view the world of like step by step by
step don't send your kids to school yeah
literally the school is indoctrinating
them into a world that doesn't [ __ ]
exist anymore right now and people oh
you don't have any kids like no I
[ __ ] got a kid now like I'm
definitely paying attention right
um and uh
what I always go back to is like what
was the per the way the school was set
up today what was the purpose it was for
the Industrial Revolution by the way it
was the perfect system for what Society
whatever that's supposed to be at this
point uh needed right is we basically
needed people who were super skilled who
could uh uh carry out tasks who could
essentially uh fit within a system like
what sane person tells an eight year old
shut up and sit down and sit there for
three hours like the eight-year-old
doesn't want to do that right like let
them go if I can live their life
um now the balance or the Counterpoint
to that is like yo we still need to
teach two plus two equals four right we
still need them to be able to read and
write we still need them to be able to
do certain things so like there has to
be education it's not just like good
luck right I hope we learn [ __ ]
um but I think the way they can do it is
very different and so uh again what it
does is like just like we talked earlier
about like Outsourcing security to the
military and all the stuff like school
is really just Outsourcing education
yeah right like you were saying the
state is better at educating my child
than I will be now there are a lot of
people I don't know what the percentage
but a very large a lot of people like I
don't have the time I have to go to work
or my kids not gonna eat I have to go do
this or this or whatever and it gets
even worse if it's a single parent or if
it's uh both parents and a household are
working uh nine-to-five job where they
don't have the luxury of leaving or
coming when they want or whatever so
like
it's important to call out that like it
is a position of uh of
um benefit and privilege like whatever
the the language you want to use is to
be able to even consider not sending
your kid to uh the local school or
whatever now there are uh variations of
this so I recently uh had this guy Dave
McIntosh on uh who is the president of
the club for growth and they're one of
their big topics or issues that they
push is this idea of school choice so a
parent says hey I am going to send my
kid to a school I'm not going to be
participating and I'm not going to do
homeschool or any of this stuff they're
going to go to school but I want to
choose which school they go to so I look
at it as like if you just get zoned in
to a district and like they go to the
school okay like you have basically no
say no anything like you're as as least
uh um kind of participatory as possible
Right like can't just go to school maybe
go to teach your parent conference or
whatever you ask what he did at school
that day like you're done
school choice is like the next step
you're like okay like I I want to make
like the macro decision you can go to
the score of this school right is this
school good is a school bad
um then you get into things like
supplemental stuff so there's the
synthesis and a bunch of these uh um uh
companies and programs that have popped
up where it's like no the kids gonna go
to school but then we're gonna
supplement the education with uh maybe
it's critical thinking or problem
solving or it's literally math and
science or whatever and then you get to
like The Homeschool the Montessori
School like there's all these variations
I see over and over and over again
talking to my friends who have young
kids uh the people who seem to be the
most engaged are the people whose kids
seem to be like the furthest along and
it's weird because you're like I'm is
that six-year-old smart or not like six
right uh but but like it's a trend that
I notice which is like very interesting
so I had a child psychologist uh I
tracked her down right I was like I need
to talk to someone okay how do you raise
a smart kid
she's like well I don't care I don't
know if I could like help with that but
like we talk about like raising a kid uh
and so uh one of the things that she
said is like one of the most powerful
things you can do for a kid is literally
just talk to them and I was like
whoa no one never told me that but how
many parents can
how many parents like uh you know it's
like the quintessential example of like
how many single moms that work two jobs
are like I am literally not next to my
kid for 18 hours a day it's just I don't
care how much you love your kid or want
to talk to your kid or whatever you just
can't talk to them or you're not there
so there's like that is a very
unfortunate situation where uh the kid
and the mother or father or whatever
just it doesn't work
on the other side I go to dinner with
people all the time and like that I just
say it publicly [ __ ] uh the number one
thing that just you will immediately get
fired as a friend is like I'll go to
dinner and somebody will be like oh man
I got out of my house got away from my
wife I'm like dude shut the [ __ ] up
right like just shut up and and the
reason is just like I don't even think
that they actually mean it it's just
like
you are so mentally soft that you can't
sit here and be like yo I want to come
to dinner to like hang out with the
people here or uh say like not actually
like I enjoy hanging out with my wife or
my my husband or my kids are like
whatever it's like
they feel like that's the thing they're
supposed to say yeah and it's just like
I don't know it's annoying so like in
some way being engaged and like caring
is like a great signal for like the
people around you are they going to end
up being productive accomplished
whatever measurement you want
on the topic of your child I know you
recently had a change of perspective on
sharing and it's something that I I
really admire because because people
look at the way they do things and then
they don't stop and question it and
based on new information some of you do
a lot and what happened in that scenario
if you'd like to share it
um so
I think I'm a just a macro scale uh I'm
at pretty much everything I ever did was
on the internet for like years uh people
knew I ate dominoes every Saturday they
knew this like they knew everything
right yeah uh and it was like fun it was
like cool it was like a little the uh I
could text my friends where I could just
put on the internet and like whatever
who cares
um and when it was like planet and I
like
whatever you know people would like say
weird [ __ ] or whatever like who cares
um
I think two things happened one like you
just kind of get to a point in your life
where you're just like yo this is like
weird now right like like people know
all this information and all this stuff
and like it just becomes something where
uh you're like is that do you want to be
uh publicly known and like the whole
like uh Tim Ferriss wrote a whole blog
of like like don't become famous right
like all this type of stuff and so like
this is not a new problem it's not some
new insight this is like literally an
entire new generation of people who came
onto the internet and built Big
audiences last five to ten years like
they're just learning the same [ __ ]
right
um so I think like that's just like at
some point you're like why like I don't
need to do this anymore I don't want to
do this anymore uh and the second thing
was with uh our daughter uh we're super
excited like we still you know it was
like amazing it was awesome we went to a
coffee shop and somebody walked up and
was like is that and used her name and I
was like oh [ __ ] no that freaked you out
understandably because it was it wasn't
by any means uh in a a malicious or
nefarious way like it was more of like a
hey I I enjoy all the content thank you
so much like all the stuff like I know
so much because I care so much yeah
which was like super endearing and like
amazing but I was just like yo this is
it's unfair to the kid it's unfair to
other people like I have two brothers
and nobody knows their names right like
they're not on the internet they're not
doing [ __ ] like uh you know one of them
I've said before is a doctor right it'd
be real weird if like he was out here
being like yo hot take on you know the
economy or politics or you know Bitcoin
or something like a patient's like bro
what did you say right so like uh it's
just like at some point it's like yeah
what again what is the goal what what
are you trying to accomplish and like I
I think there's a lot of people who are
realizing
um there are benefits to content
internet all stuff uh but also there's
like downsides definitely just like find
your own place like and I don't think
it's fair to judge anyone who posts
everything I don't think it's fair to
judge people who are like I'm not on the
internet like again I I have this saying
uh with Plano like whenever we see
somebody doing something that like from
the outside looks weird I always just
ask myself like you think they're happy
if they're happy that's [ __ ] amazing
right and like who cares what they're
doing right like they're happy if
they're not happy they're like damn like
that's like really unfortunate like I I
hope that they get you know can be
happier uh doing it and like I think
that's a great way to just kind of
filter you know what you want to do yeah
I like that I'd like to close out with a
few questions here
um what is the best possible future
invention or Discovery for humankind
if I knew that I'd be [ __ ] Rich well
then you gotta execute it yeah what is
the best invention for humankind in the
future
um
it's probably something that we don't
even like understand right now uh
frankly
um but like things that are within like
the realm of imagination maybe uh
it seems like we should probably go to
space like for like Mars yes but like
even further like there's [ __ ] out there
right like are there aliens probably
um so like that whole like just like how
do we
um how do we solve science problems
to get human questions answered seems
like super interesting
um so if you think of that as like the
furthest thing away from our our human
bodies like let's go try to solve that
then like the Other Extreme is like we
don't even [ __ ] know that much about
our own bodies right so like all the
like uh uh biology
um all of the uh uh brain computer
interfaces like just like everything to
do with like your body and and
optimizing uh understanding how do we
solve you know can we solve death right
like oh that sounds [ __ ] nuts but
like maybe right is aging a disease like
that's that's pretty interesting idea
like how do we how do we uh affect that
so I think it's like one extreme is like
as far away from the body as possible
the other stream is like literally who
we are as individuals like better
understanding that
um and and then I actually think uh
one of the things we've learned over
time in history is technology constantly
replaces what humans do and it frees
humans up to do new things
um and I would argue that actually the
rate at which we are doing that right
now is very slow compared to other
points in history and so uh
it doesn't even matter what we actually
do as much as like could we just speed
up the rate and it's like rate of
innovation rate of automation rate of uh
productivity like there's a bunch of
different ways you can measure it but if
we could accelerate that if you looked
across Humanity that would probably have
one of the biggest impacts and within
that would be all these like sub uh uh
things like inventions uh um you know
more efficiencies like all these other
things but just like the rate of
progress how do you like bend that
upwards
um which like sounds [ __ ] amazing I
don't know how to do it most people
would say that we are going at
exponentially faster rate but [ __ ] no
you you don't think so
if you go out in the street right now
people are driving gas cars yeah they're
doing the same [ __ ] in the early 1900s
but there's 120 years later there are
more people on electric than ever before
sure so that's that's growth it is uh it
is the right path like like we will get
there uh it's just taking way longer
than I think most people thought right
like if you think uh I mean SpaceX is
what 22 years old uh or 20 years old
something like that uh I think Tesla is
like 14 15 years old right like it's
been a decade and a half
people don't [ __ ] what's going on I
went outside like 90 of the cars are not
electric what the [ __ ] happening right
so like again it takes a long time right
and all that um the other thing is uh
things that we thought would have
already happened now haven't happened so
it goes back to the Bill Gates quote we
you know overestimate in two years
underestimate in 10 years
um so like that's interesting uh and and
then I think also
um we have like an uh ambition crisis
where uh if you go talk I spent a lot of
time talking people who want to start
companies right and some of the time it
is I just want to learn sometimes it's
we're looking at it from an investment
standpoint sometimes people pitching us
like Halestorm company together or
whatever
it is depressing as to uh the north star
that so many people pick they're like uh
okay so I'm on like level one I want to
build something for level two and I
think it's refreshing when you see
somebody like I'm on level one I'm
building something for level one
thousand and you're like that sounds
insane right and so I'll give you
um I'll give you one example that I
think some people in Tech know but but
people outside might not um so varda uh
is company uh Delian
um and his co-founders start a business
they essentially want to send
manufacturing equipment up into space
already like that's crazy then they want
to manufacture things in space and they
want to bring it back down onto earth
right and you're like why would you do
that and there's all these advantages
doing it at zero gravity it's cost it's
like like whatever right
how many people are working on a company
that is the equivalent ambition level of
like we should do space manufacturing
right just not that many and so like
when you see that like one I know
dillian right and and uh would bet on
him all day long but then you see the
ambition you're like dude that's
something I want to invest in like yes I
want to be an investor in that business
um there's just not that many of those
and I don't know if it's necessarily
like oh there used to be tons of them
and now there's like not as many like
that's probably an arrogant view for us
today to have
um but I do think that like you can
level up the ambition of a group by just
one person like Elon Musk has probably
uh uh outsourced or like uh through like
osmosis like sent ambition through a lot
of people because like well this dude
could literally land rockets that he
just used I probably shouldn't be
working on like how to click the ad
right like like there's something in
between Landing reusable rockets and
like hey let's optimize this button I've
done it I get it right like whatever
yeah like I I change the colors of the
button or are they square around on the
edges like I get it
um uh usually around
uh it's like click the button or like
land the rocket those are the extremes I
just think that like can you pull people
okay I want to click the button but like
what's the next thing okay I'm doing the
next thing what's the next thing after
that and if you pull them closer and
closer to like the high ambition stuff
it's just better for Humanity in general
I think that's a beautiful place to come
to a close Anthony thank you so much for
taking the time I'm really grateful for
you you're someone thinking and living
in the future and somebody who is able
to express themselves and where they're
going so clearly so I want to thank you
for that and appreciate everything
you've given to this podcast yeah look I
I enjoyed it I don't know if I'm living
in the future I'm uh probably behind but
uh doing my best thanks appreciate you